los equipos de rescate utilizan todos
los recursos posibles para buscar a
supervivientes del deslizamiento de
tierras que sacudió al país el viernes
Honestamente las posibilidades de
sobrevivientes son bajas porque ya es el
segundo día los cuerpos de las víctimas
bajo el aguanieve tienen menos oxígeno y
esto puede causar problemas
respiratorios tenemos prevista una
operación de búsqueda de 24 horas que
puede ampliarse a 7 días
[Música]
el viernes antes del amanecer la
catástrofe se produjo en el camping de
una granja ecológica las afueras de la
capital koala donde se alojaban a más de
90 personas
estábamos durmiendo y de repente oímos
un fuerte ruido
después se produjo el corrimiento de
tierras pudimos escapar y rescatar a
nuestros amigos y gracias a Dios
sobrevivimos
la tienda que estaba a nuestro lado fue
completamente arrasada no queda nada y
no podíamos hacer nada
en Malasia movimientos de tierra son
frecuentes tras las Fuertes lluvias de
fin de año motivo por el que el gobierno
ha impuesto leyes estrictas sobre la
construcción en laderas la granja que
gestionaba el camping no tenía permiso y
ahora se arriesga a una sanción si la
justicia reconoce su responsabilidad en
esta tragedia para evitar nuevos
incidentes todos los campings y
merenderos del Estado permanecerán
cerrados durante una